se baigner dans une eau à 28° pendant
les vacances scolaires c'est possible à
saint jean les la piscine a rouvert ce
jeudi 11 février un bassin extérieur il
rouverture associé à un protocole
sanitaires strictes validé par l' agence
régionale de santé et la préfecture des
yvelines
on arrive à laquelle donc on donne ses
coordonnées
ensuite donc on soit une petite fiche
numérotés et cette petite fiche en fait
elle va suivre va nous suivre du début à
la sortie de l'équipement c'est à dire
que ce numéro on va le retrouver sur
notre cabine de change sur notre casier
de façon à pouvoir angers nos affaires
et puis on est au bord de la piscine
là où on va pouvoir poser sur nos
affaires également de faire en toute
sécurité
la rouverture de ce bassin de 25 m et la
toute première de ce type dans les
yvelines
on se satisfait de la moindre ré
ouverture j'ai mon collègue de maisons
laffitte qui est là aujourd'hui j'espère
que aussi réfléchi ça à réouvrir leur
piscine voilà je crois qu'il faut il
faut être pragmatique qu'il faut faire
preuve de souplesse et dès qu'on peut ré
ouvrir quelque chose il faut le faire
quarante-six personnes peuvent être
accueillies en même temps dans le bassin
depuis sa réouverture la plupart des
créneaux sont complets ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas nager du coup
ça me faisait plaisir de revenir
et j'avais jamais j étais jamais allé
dans la piscine extérieure du coup
c'était très sympa alors ouverture c'est
sympathique ça donne un peu l'impression
aux 10es de bassins un peu suédois
norvégiens avec la fumée tout par contre
il ya un petit peu de monde donc faut
vraiment en programmant nager quoi le
droit d'entrée est à 8 euros aucune
réservation n'est nécessaire la piscine
sera ouverte tous les jours du lundi au
dimanche de 9h30 à 16h30